let's go to josiah in salt lake city
josiah what's going on how can we help
hey dr d and rachel thanks for taking my
call
to keep a long story short um for for a
little bit now i've had some suspicion
that my brother was stealing money
through
uh various sources from my disabled
mother
i confronted him about it and let my
mother know what was going on
um he still has not been 100 honest with
either me or my mother
my issue is this isn't a first time
saying he's stolen from me before
i'm just finding it hard to keep a
relationship with both my brother
and my mom because now she's she's
looking at
as if it's a minor issue um
and i'm worried that it's just gonna
bleed or dry and eventually he's just
gonna
be gone and i'm gonna be stuck trying to
fund
her for the rest of her life yeah
you man i hate this for you josiah
you're wrestling with
um i can hear as you're processing this
you're turning in this into a future
math problem
but man i want to bring you back to
right here this just hurts man and i
hate that for you what's
what struggles does your mom have um
she's
since i was 10 so about 20 years ago she
was diagnosed with arts
she's now just got multiple other health
issues
um she's she's basically been bedridden
my whole life that's hard man
so here's a challenge that everybody
with this type of family situation deals
with we all are
we love our brothers and sisters our
moms and dads we are all trained to
um and socialized and it's just the
right thing i mean you
you take care of your family right you
default to that and
unfortunately there's these moments like
you're experiencing when
your brother is still your brother but
he also becomes that grown man that's
hurting mom
right and at some point you have to lean
into that
and do hard things which like call the
police
and if your brother's stealing from your
mom and you've got proof of it
and your mom is not in a position to
take care of herself then that's the
logical responsibility it's hard and it
feels like you're violating that family
what i'll tell you it's it's a phrase i
use all the time but it's not by your
hand but it's in your lap
right you didn't cause this you're not
gonna be the you're not gonna be the
result
you're not going to be the person who
who broke up the family your brother
is making some really reckless um wrong
decisions taking advantage of your mom
and um now it's your situation to
to to deal with right because your
brother's not acting with character
right
and josiah does he have does he still
have the ability
to steal from your mom like is it
accounts numbers that he has
yeah so i i actually kind of put the
kibosh on that um
she she because she was so dependent on
me and him she had her he had her debit
card
and so i i forced him to give it back to
her and i told her that because now they
have that information that she needs to
change her her card number and
everything immediately yeah
yeah yeah so i think it's i think that's
the right thing to do brother and
i think you're it's just one of those
moments where you find yourself in a
hard position you didn't cause this you
didn't
it's not not your fault but now you're
the person
who's going to be responsible be the
person of integrity that's going to have
to turn and deal with it and so that
means getting the authorities involved
if your brother
is going to continue to kind of be the
person that steals from your mom
terrible and then josiah too i mean i
think focusing on the present is
extremely important right now
but also to know long term like it
probably is going to be you taking care
of your mom
i mean if she's if she is bedridden and
she doesn't have a way to make an income
then she is going to need to eat right i
mean like and your brother is
obviously not a dependable trustworthy
person so
i would go ahead and emotionally say
okay
what can i do to help my mom in the
future because it probably is going to
be you josiah so i'd be thinking about
that as well
and those are those are we just talked
to millions of people who are faced with
those situations
mom and dad don't want to sign over you
know accounts or they won't can't join
accounts and
i'm just trying to do the math on what
my future might look like and sometimes
it's
there is no easy answer to that right
right but there's a responsible answer
you can
pretend it's not going to happen or you
can pretend yeah this is probably going
to be us
you your future spouse you know we've
got to start planning for this
financially
what does that look like yeah